Trascrizione: Javier Vázquez
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Immaginate
di essere su una collina,
18.000 anni fa.
È il picco dell’era glaciale.
Guardate le mandrie lontane,
che sono sempre meno abbondanti.
I ghiacci coprono
la Scandinavia, la Scozia,
scendono dalle Alpi nella pianura.
Il clima è arido e l’Europa è una steppa.
Gli sciamani dipingono
gli animali nel fondo delle grotte,
iniziando quell’opera
di rappresentazione simbolica del mondo
che caratterizza
il nostro modo di pensare.
Ma il mondo sta per cambiare.
Nel giro di duemila anni,
fra 12.000 e 10.000 anni fa,
le temperature aumentano.
Il clima diventa più mite, più piovoso,
e soprattutto molto più stabile.
Questa curva mostra la temperatura
ricostruita al centro della Groenlandia
dai carotaggi glaciali
e quello che vedete è
che negli ultimi 10.000 anni, l’Olocene,
le temperature sono più alte,
ma soprattutto sono molto meno variabili,
molto più stabili, invece,
nei 40 mila anni precedenti,
le temperature sono state
molto più oscillanti, fluttuanti,
da un millennio all’altro.
E, allora,
abbiamo la nostra prima rivoluzione.
Si passa dai cacciatori
e raccoglitori a una società agricola.
Cambia completamente,
cambia il mondo.
Nasce una società
più strutturata, molto più complicata.
Ci sono classi sociali diverse:
ci sono i contadini, i commercianti,
i funzionari, i sacerdoti,
i soldati, i re e gli imperatori.
E cresce la disuguaglianza.
L’indice di Gini misura
come sono distribuite le risorse
in una popolazione.
Vale zero,
se sono distribuite omogeneamente.
Vale uno, se sono concentrate
nelle mani di un solo individuo.
L’indice di Gini, per una società
di cacciatori e raccoglitori,
è stimato essere fra 0,15 e 0,20.
Nell’Impero Romano
si stima che valesse 0,4, 0,45,
quindi le ricchezze sono più concentrate,
con un cambiamento
che continuerà anche dopo
e  su cui torneremo alla fine.
Il tempo passa, si fanno nuove scoperte,
e, in particolare,
si scopre la macchina a vapore.
Si impara a utilizzare
il carbone, il petrolio, il metano
e sono combustibili relativamente facili
da estrarre, molto facili da trasportare
e fortemente energetici
e, quindi, abbiamo la seconda rivoluzione,
che cambia di nuovo il mondo:
La Rivoluzione industriale.
Le città diventano più grandi,
le popolazioni vanno in città,
sempre più persone
lavorano nelle fabbriche,
la società diventa
più complessa e tutto è più veloce
ed è il mondo in cui viviamo oggi,
il nostro mondo moderno.
Ma abbiamo un problema.
I combustibili fossili,
quando sono bruciati,
buttano in aria anidride carbonica, CO2.
Questa curva rappresenta
la concentrazione di anidride carbonica
negli ultimi diecimila anni.
Dagli anni Cinquanta,
uno scienziato chiamato Charles Keeling
ha cominciato a misurare la
concentrazione in atmosfera,
vedendo che saliva
da 300 parti per milione,
300 centimetri cubi
in un metro cubo d’aria,
a 420, che è oggi,
e sta continuando a crescere.
E se ricostruiamo la concentrazione
nei diecimila anni precedenti,
vediamo che è sempre stata
sotto di 280 parti per milione.
La ricostruiamo
andando a vedere la composizione
delle bolle d’aria
intrappolate nel ghiaccio.
E dobbiamo andare
indietro di quattro milioni di anni
per trovare concentrazioni
di CO2 analoghe a quelle attuali.
Il che vuol dire
che allora era un mondo diverso,
era un mondo
molto più caldo, molto più violento.
Ma perché ho detto
era molto più caldo e molto più violento?
Perché l’anidride carbonica,
come il metano, come il vapor d’acqua,
sono gas che hanno
un effetto cosiddetto “serra”.
La radiazione solare arriva
sulla Terra, l’atmosfera è trasparente,
scalda la superficie della Terra,
la quale riemette radiazione infrarossa
che viene assorbita
dai gas serra,
che si scaldano
e ne riemettono
un po’ verso l’alto
e un po’ verso il basso.
E quando la buttano
verso il basso, riscaldano ulteriormente.
L’effetto serra è una buona cosa
perché permette la vita sulla Terra,
è come una coperta
che ci protegge dal gelo cosmico,
ma, quando la coperta
diventa troppo spessa,
sudiamo
e la Terra sta sudando.
La temperatura,
abbiamo visto prima, è aumentata di 1,1°
e 1,4° negli ultimi cento anni,
se andiamo a considerare le terre emerse,
più di 2°,
se consideriamo l’Artico,
la Siberia, il Nord America.
Ma non è solo la temperatura che importa,
perché l’aumento delle temperature
porta a un aumento del livello del mare
e porta soprattutto
cambiamenti nel ciclo dell’acqua.
Questo grafico mostra la precipitazione
come distribuita la differenza fra gli
ultimi trent'anni e i precedenti
trent'anni.
Quello che vedete che la quantità totale
è più o meno rimane la stessa ma cambia
la distribuzione spaziale e anche quella
temporale ma la distribuzione spaziale ci
porta a vedere per esempio in Europa che
nella parte nord piove molto di più nel
bacino mediterraneo piove molto di meno.
Questi sono ripeto i dati
degli ultimi 60 anni.
E poiché cambia anche la distribuzione
temporale vuol dire che la precipitazione
è anche più concentrata del tempo quindi
più intensa e che i periodi secchi sono
molto più lunghi e quindi ecco che
abbiamo rischio di alluvioni.
Rischio di inondazioni costiere.
Rischio di siccità prolungate e gli
incendi che seguono queste con queste le
condizioni di siccità .
Il pianeta in pericolo no.
Il pianeta è passato attraverso catastrofi
inimmaginabili momenti in cui
sono scomparsi il 90 per cento delle
specie esistenti il pianeta è
sopravvissuto e sta benissimo forse
sarebbe anche meglio senza di noi però .
Questi cambiamenti climatici che sono
sempre più veloci stanno mettendo
a rischio la nostra società il nostro la
nostra civiltà la nostra sopravvivenza
forse no ma il nostro benessere
certamente sì .
E allora dobbiamo agire rapidamente come
abbiamo detto con maggiore tecnologia
migliore tecnologia tecnologia che sia che
porti a ridurre le emissioni a usare
le energie rinnovabili e che porti a
migliori tecniche di allevamento e di
agricoltura l'abbiamo visto in tanti
esempi anche accettare compromessi per
esempio temporanei come lo stoccaggio
della CO2 nel sottosuolo ma che non siano
un alibi per non cambiare niente.
Però questi cambiamenti sono costosi.
E allora dobbiamo chiederci che torniamo
alle ricchezze chi paga che cosa.
Chi paga la transizione energetica le
aziende multinazionali che producono
energia o gli utenti e gli utilizzatori
sia aziende sia privati.
E chi paga il non far niente.
CHI PAGA LA riparare i danni dei
cambiamenti climatici i governi che
pagano i danni delle alluvioni degli
incendi e così via quindi i cittadini e
quindi il discorso di come sono
distribuiti i costi e
i costi è fondamentale.
E allora arriviamo di nuovo l'indice di
Gini chi sceglie la strada oggi l'indice
di Gini è ancora più alto che non
nell'Impero romano e quindi
sostanzialmente dà un enorme potere
decisionale nelle mani di pochi.
L'Unione Europea ha dichiarato che a
decidere devono essere le istituzioni
che rappresentano i cittadini.
Insieme ai privati insieme al capitale
ma non lasciando la scelta
nelle mani di pochi.
Non vogliamo.
1 umanità B.
Siamo all'alba della terza rivoluzione e
dobbiamo scegliere dove vogliamo andare.
L'umanità B è quella del tardo umanesimo e
quella di ricchezze concentrate sempre
di più in poche mani in persone che magari
vivono sotto forma di bit in
macchine come il trans umanesimo derivante
vorrebbe mentre il resto è
un'umanità disperata questo
non lo vogliamo.
Non vogliamo la distopia
di Blade Runner, di Brasile
e di tanti altri film
Vogliamo imparare a usare e a sviluppare
una tecnologia che lavori con la natura
la fotosintesi artificiale.
Per esempio e così molte altre molte altre
possibilità che utilizzi e leggi la
natura che sia in armonia con la natura
perché noi siamo parte della natura
quindi migliori tecnologie ma questo vuol
dire tecnologia sostenibile e che porti
a un mondo più armonico e nello
stesso tempo più giusto.
Grazie.